وفي جنوب قطاع غزه ايضا افاد مراسل
الجزيره بان قوات الاحتلال نسفت عددا من
المنازل في بلده الغراره او القرار فيما
شنت المقاتلات الاسرائيليه
غارات جويه وقصفت المدفعيه بنس هيله وزنه
وعبس شرق خان
يونس
ينضم الينا من مستشفى ناصر في خان يونس
مراسل الجزيره مؤمن الشرافي مؤمن اخر
التحديثات من جنوب قطع غزه 11د ع شهيدا في
القصف الاسرائيلي المتواصل على خان يونس
ماذا في
التفاصيل نعم غنو في التفاصيل هو 11 شهيدا
منذ ساعات فجر هذا اليوم وحتى هذه اللحظه
نتيجه تواصل القصف والغارات الاسرائيليه
على مختلف المناطق في مدينه خان يونس سواء
المناطق الشرقيه او حتى وسط المدينه
بالاضافه الى المحور الجنوبي الشرقي حيث
منطقه قيزان النجار الغارات الاسرائيليه
لا تتوقف على مدار الساعه وعمليات قصف
المنازل والمربعات السكنيه تزايدت وتيرتها
خلال الساعات الاخيره كما نشهد اشتباكات
في المحور الجنوبي الشمالي الشرقي من
مدينه خان يونس تحديدا في محيط شارع خمسه
القريب من شارع القسام ومنطقه المحطه التي
تتمركز فيها اليات جيش الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي ويبدو ان اعمده الخان هذه
ناجمه عن قصف اسرائيلي استهدف منشاه ما او
مصنعا في تلك المنطقه حيث تدور اشتباكات
بين المقاومه الفلسطينيه وقوات الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي في شارع القسام القريب من
منطقه البلد في في وسط مدينه خان يونس
وايضا تستهدف دبابات جيش الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي حي الامل القريب من شارع
القسام بالقذائف الصاروخيه وكذلك قناصه
جيش الاحتلال الاسرائيلي يستهدفون
المواطنين وايضا النازحين داخل مستشفى
الامل وفي محيطه بالرصاص ما ادى الى
استشهاد اثنين واصابه العدد اخر بجروح
متفاوته نتيجه استهدافه من قبل قناصه جيش
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي في هذه المنطقه التي
تدور فيها اشتباكات ضاريه بين المقاومه
الفلسطينيه وقوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي
بالاضافه الى المحور الجنوبي الشرقي من
مدينه خان يونس تحديدا في محيط كليه
العلوم
والتكنولوجيا التي تتمركز داخلها اليات
ودبابات جيش الاحتلال الاسرائيلي حيث
تستهدفها المقاومه الفلسطينيه بالصواريخ
المضاده للدروع وايضا بقذائف الهون
بالاضافه الى استهداف تجمعات اخرى
وتمركزات اخرى لجيش الاحتلال في منطقه
كتيبه والمحطه وايضا تدور اشتباكات شرق
بلده بني سهيله وشرق عبسان ومناطق اخرى من
مدينه خان
[تصفيق]
يونس مؤمن لو تسمح لي نعود للتعليق على
هذه اعمله الدخان التي شاهدناها سويا اين
تركزت تحديدا وكم تبعد عن المستشفى التي
تتواجد
[موسيقى]
فيها هذه مده الدخان تبعد عن المستشفى ما
يقارب كيلو متر واحد على الاقل اي في في
محيط شارع خمسه وهو شارع قريب من وسط
مدينه خان يونس وقريب ايضا من منطقه
القراره في الشمال الشرقي الشمال الشرقي
من مدينه خان يونس هذه المنطقه اشتعلت
فيها الاشتباكات والقصف الاسرائيلي منذ
ساعات الفجر مع دفع قوات الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي مزيد من التعزيزات العسكريه
وايضا الدبابات الى تلك المنطقه في محاوله
للتوغل اكثر في هذه المنطقه وسط غطاء جوي
كثيف من قبل الطائرات الحربيه وايضا
طائرات الاستطلاع بالاضافه الى اعتلاء
قناصه جيش الاحتلال عدد من المباني في
شارع القسام على وجه التحديد واستهداف
المواطنين في حي الامل الى الغرب من شارع
القسام بالرصاص الحي وايضا يسمع دوي
انفجارات بين فينه واخرى في تلك المنطقه
وهي ناجمه عن الاشتباكات وايضا قيام
دبابات جيش الاحتلال الاسرائيلي باستهداف
تلك المنطقه والمربعات السكنيه التي
يتواجد بها السكان حتى هذه اللحظه وايضا
محيط مستشفى الامل التابع لجمعيه الهلال
الاحمر الفلسطيني بالصواريخ والقذائف
الصاروخيه هذه الجبهه او هذا المحور فتح
مجددا منذ ساعات الفجر وحتى هذهه اللحظه
تستمر فيها الاشتباكات بعد تصاعد وتيره
الاشتباكات في المحور الجنوبي الشرقي في
منطقه زان النجار وايضا منطقه بير عيا
التي كانت قريبه تبعد مئات الامتار عن
مجمع ناصر الطبي والتي كانت تقتحم تتوغل
من خلالها اليات ودبابات جيش الاحتلال الى
محيط مجمع ناصر الطبي ومن ثم عادت ادراجها
وانسحبت من تلك المنطقه وزاها تعزيزات
عسكريه اكبر واكثر الى المحور الشمالي
الشرقي من المدينه تحديدا في شارع محيط
شارع خمسه وشارع القسام في مدينه يونس
وهذه المنطقه هي التي تتصاعد منها اعمده
الدخان انت تحدثت ان هذه الاشتباكات وهذه
التوغ بدات منذ ساعات الصباح الاولى هل لك
ان تحدثنا عن او تحدد لنا اكثر من اي
اتجاهات في خان يونس دخلت هذه التعزيزات
الاسرائيليه دخلت هذه التعزيزات من اكثر
من محور من المحور الشرقي من مدينه
خانيونس حيث تقع بلده بن سهيله وعباس
ومناطق اخرى في المنطقه الشرقيه توغلت من
خلالها
وايضا ضافت اليها تعزيزات اخرى من
التمركزات التي تتواجد بها قوات الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي منذ بدء العمليه البريه تحديدا
في منطقتي الكتيبه والمحطه القريبه من
منطقه البلد وسط مدينه خانيونس دفعت
بتعزيزات من هذين المحورين باتجاه المحور
الشمالي الشرقي تحديدا في شارع خمسه الذي
كانت تسيطر عليه قوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي
قبل ان تنسحب منه منذ ايام ثم عاود التوغل
مجددا الى هذه المنطقه في محاوله منها
للدخول الى شارع القسام المؤدي الى منطقه
البلد وايضا يؤدي الى منطقه حي الامل حيث
يتواجد مقر جمعيه الهلال الاحمر الفلسطيني
وايضا مستشفى الامل الذي يؤوي الالاف من
النازحين الذين احتموا داخل اسوار هذا
المستشفى مع شده القصف والغارات
الاسرائيليه خلال الفتره الماضيه على
مدينه خان يونس تدور في هذا المحور على
وجه التحديد اشتباكات ضاريه خل منذ ساعات
الصباح وحتى هذه اللحظه بين المقاومه التي
تحاول التصدي لمحاولات توغل وتقدم
اسرائيليه لوصول الى عمق منطقه البلد في
وسط مدينه خان يونس وايضا فتح محور جديد
والتوغل الى الغرب من مدينه خان يونس حيث
حي الامل المتاخم
لمخيم خان يونس للاجئين والذي يقع الى غرب
المدينه بالتوازي هناك اشتباكات ايضا في
المحور الجنوبي الشرقي من المدينه ويبدو
ان قوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي تحاول
الاطباق على مدينه خان يونس من خلال
محورين المحور الجنوبي الشرقي وايضا
الشمالي الشرقي والتوغل فيهما للسيطره على
اكبر مساحه جغرافيه او الوصول الى اهداف
معينه لدى جيش الاحتلال الاسرائيلي سرايا
القدس في هذه الاثناء اعلنت انها تخوض
اشتباكات ضاريه مع قوات العدو الصهيوني
وفق ما تقول بالاسلحه الرشاشه والمناسبه
شرق وجنوب خانيونس اذا مؤمن ال محاولات
التوغل هذه لا تقتصر فقط على الشرق في
محاوله منها لل الترجل او للتوجه غربا
وانما كذلك من الناحيه الجنوبيه كل هذه
التوغ بهدف الوصول يعني ما الذي تحاول
قوات الاحتلال ان تصل اليه
جغرافيا تحاول قوات الاحتلال الوصول الى
مناطق جديده لم تصلها من قبل تحديدا في
منطقه حي الامل وايضا التوغل اكثر في
منطقه البلد في وسط المدينه من خلال
المحور الشمالي الشرقي الذي تحدثنا عنه
قبل قليل وتقوم بعمليات تفتيش في المناطق
التي تصل اليها بحثا عن انفاق للمقاومه او
مقرات او مواقع للمقاومه في تلك المناطق
وايضا من المحور الشمالي الجنوبي الشرقي
من المدينه حيث منطقه قزان الجار ومنطقه
بعيه اخر نقطه وصلت اليها اليات ودبابات
جيش الاحتلال الاسرائيلي حاولت التوغل
اكثر ايضا الى من المحور الجنوبي الشرقي
للاطباق يبدو على المدينه من هذين
المحورين والتوغل اكثر باتجاه المنطقه
الغربيه من المدينه لكن حتى هذه اللحظه
دبابات واليات جيش الاحتلال الاسرائيلي
تتواجد في محيط شارع خمسه وايضا شارع
القسام ولم ولم نسجل اي توغل بري اكثر الى
اتجاه المنطقه الغربيه حيث منطقه حي الامل
وايضا من المحور الجنوبي الشرقي كانت
تتواجد عشرات الاليات في منطقه بير عيا ثم
عادت ادراجها واعادت انتشارها قوات واليات
جيش الاحتلال في تلك المنطقه ولم يتبقى سو
عدد محدود من الاليات في المطقه بير عيا
الى الجنوب الشرقي من مدينه خانيونس كل
ذلك يترافق مع غارات جويه كثيفه وايضا
احزمه ناريه تنفذها طائرات جيش الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي تنسف من خلاله مربعات سكنيه
باكملها هي غير ماهوله بالسكان نزح نزح
منها السكان منذ بدء العمليه البريه
بالاضافه الى مباني ومراكز تجاريه في
منطقه البلد التي كانت تعد عصب حياه
بالنسبه لمدينه خانيونس قبل الحرب
الاسرائيليه على غزه شكرا لك من مستشفى
ناص في خان يونس وراسل الجزيره مؤمن
الشرافي